hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
hey who's this
Morgan Han from how to booze with Morgan
and Ashley how to blondes make a ride on
Instagram that's her I hear people hey
Morgan yes have you ever put out a mean
tweet yeah
transition smoothly Jimmy Kimmel edition
mean tweets I've been in I mean facebook
status update
Oh back in the day before I think that
was before Twitter oh my god how old are
we oh my god
you mean a Mustang ooh I could drive a
Mustang ah I was talking about just
physic okay sorry this doesn't say
celebrity mean tweets so I don't not
sure what this is and fiddly might be a
little different
might just be mean tweets I'm excited
though let's find out oh it's alright a
roast some of your mean tweets some
people that have tweeted this is cool
celebrities are gonna read mean tweets
about Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel at Home Depot
turns out I was just sloppy Jimmy Kimmel
you are in jackass sucker keep your
mouth shut and do your little TV show or
get the out of our
Jimmy Kimmel you represent everything I
hate about myself here we go
there you go for your birthday Jimmy
some thing at euphoric underscore mania
rice is jimmy kimmel cross-eyed or just
ridiculously ugly stupid stupid Jimmy
Kimmel go second I think you're doing
comedy God like a deformed my hideous of
gods such as ancient Greece's have
[Music]
emphasized to me bozo is still guarding
me flabby body what the get to the gym
man do you really shave your pits scary
is that saying fat kid from win Ben
Stein's money grow up to become that fat
kid from win Ben Stein's view replaces
nobody you have a dead ringer foot Dumbo
you still look like a potato
now you're just a hairy potato so you're
extra girls I disagree I think Jimmy
Kimmel looks like a slightly Bluto to
Carson Daly but not as funny kind of
self but something fantastic
[Music]
go wrap your ballsack around your neck
choke yourself then put your head up
your butt put yourself in my shoes
you're a piece of your job is to pollute
the airwaves with your worthless big
giant turd Jimmy Kimmel your show blows
Brown donkey balls
go play with Howard Stern dude Jimmy
Kimmel man Jimmy Kimmel do you like
Jimmy Kimmel yes I do like Jimmy Kimmel
I don't know if he's my favorite one
Jimmy Kimmel or Jimmy Fallon which would
you pick Kimmel for real I would pick
him oh yeah I think Emal's a little
darker and his humor and he seems to go
for more real questions or ass pounds
like which is fine
I enjoy Fallon did you see any the
fill-in guests yes like that Jennifer
Lawrence I really liked her she did
great Jennifer Lawrence and she asked
like the raw real questions to Kim
Kardashian and I feel like because of
the way Jimmy Kimmel is that opens the
door for someone like Jenna
for Lauren's to do that yeah if she did
that on Fallon it would be like whoa
whoa no but on Kimmel it's like yeah
that's perfect for what Kimmel is and I
like that edginess of Kimmel and there's
something about him where he has this
cool hybrid of talk-show host but also
kind of just the real dude which I do
appreciate
give me a talk show Pitts is that simple
you know audition
well these sweets are not very clever
man there's something reassuring when I
watch like a I mean tweets I do YouTube
everybody's mean there's a lot of dicks
out there who say like the meanest thing
things you just wouldn't say to someone
in person but a stranger would not say
to you in person they'd be too much of
it yeah
people constantly insole me thanks is
that your own that people can say [ __ ]
to someone Smith if you just have the
balls if you just have the balls to say
fortunately most people don't I do I
think the boss yeah I think so
I've seen them reassuring about it when
when I feel like the celebrities can
have a laugh about the tweet when you're
doing u2 and you're by yourself and you
and you see these mean hate comments and
you're like by yourself it can be like
oh that kind of hurts after a while but
when you're like with a group of people
are putting it out there and everyone's
having a laugh about it you realize it's
not a big deal these people like
everybody says yeah everybody yeah
exactly no matter how famous or how
successful you get you're gonna get a
lot of hate any money that has more than
you get hate yeah did you see his the
thing about Vegas when Jimmy Kimmel did
his speech he was crying a lot and he
was like really holding back his tears
it was like real tears it wasn't like
I'm putting on display you know it's
real when someone's fighting to hold
back right you can always tell and I
really respected that even in the
comments there people were like this is
fake he's just I'm like yeah he's the
Jimmy Kimmel is known to be a great
dramatic actor yeah so even in that
scenario he would get crap one
it's crap I always find it funny though
that like the mean tweets people a
people who tweet mean or comment so mean
it's like why are you making fun of
people that literally like sneeze and a
million dollars comes out of their nose
make fun of them sure what are you doing
yeah exactly what are you doing right
now you're making fun of like impression
call her an idiot caller what you want
that chicks gonna have money for life
she must not be that yeah cuz if you're
John person if you're dumb and you have
a lot of money you're not gonna have
money for long cuz you're done well a
lot of the people that we think are dumb
our smart are really smart they want to
know I are smart because persona and
exactly exactly they're they're they're
business people Kim Kardashian's a
businesswoman even Paris Hilton is she's
a businesswoman people who have worked
with her and know her that I've met have
said like she's actually really smart
this actually system that's the persona
yeah of what sells I say stop me and
tweeting and go out there and make more
money love is the answer not hate as
we've learned from the mean tweets yeah
this would be a much less interesting
segment if it was love tweets it's not
that you can't have a segment on show
who's gonna watch that I would yeah we
would don't you love the videos where
people are just nice and kind to each
other
look I want to kick a kid as much as the
next person I get pissed off but like
that is twice today you said yeah yeah
hey listen subscribe click that
notification Belle Morgan Han on the
YouTube channel how to use with Morgan
and Ashley and you could follow her on
instagram at how to blondes make a right
don't you wanna do it again
let's cut off your chick leave the
Sabine tweets on Instagram everyone
likes to follow a good-looking blonde on
on Instagram but now you get to in this
package I mean see what we do yeah yeah
you made a work that say mean things
says the moment we've made
it she'll reply